to present my next award we have a
distinguished composer who is a
five-time Oscar winner and a beautiful
actress who's a first-time nominee mr.
John Green and miss Diahann Carroll
thank you it's our privilege to present
the awards for musical scoring the first
category is for Best Original dramatic
score may we have some music maestro
something first the nominees lucky
paycheck Jerry Goldsmith for Chinatown
Nino Rota and carmine Coppola for The
Godfather
talk to Richard Rodney Bennett for
Murder on the Orient Express
Alex Nora for shanks John Williams for
the towering inferno
and the winner is thank you sir Tatum
O'Neal the winners are
Nina Rocha and Carmen
I wish that Nina wrote over here I'm
sure he would have been as happy as I am
and even happier we worked very nicely
together he's a splendid musician and
wonderful friend a good gentleman I want
to thank my son Francis Ford Coppola for
being up here because without him I
wouldn't be here
however if if I wasn't here he wouldn't
be here either
right
next award the next award is for best
scoring either original song score and
adaptation or adaptation and the
nominees are the Great Gatsby adapted by
Nelson Riddle the little prince song
score by alan jay lerner and Frederick
Loewe adapted by Angela Morley and
Douglas gamle phantom of the paradise
song score by Paul Williams adapted by
Paul Williams and George Allison Tipton
and the winner is thank you the winner
is Nelson Riddle for the great gas
I'd like to thank Jack Clayton the
English director who had enough faith in
me I'd like to thank Mark Newman who
made it possible for me to get the
picture on this side of the ocean and
I'd like to thank Bill Stinson for his
friendly persuasion